good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I'm on
vacation on the shores of Lake Michigan
and last night Twilight looked like this
I learned yesterday that the first half
hour or so after the Sun sets is called
civil twilight because it's considered
by some governments to be legally still
daytime like centuries ago nighttime
burglary was often considered a more
serious crime than daytime burglary and
criminals would sometimes seek lesser
sentences by claiming that they'd robbed
a house not at night but during civil
twilight I just loved that for a civil
twilight the adjective civil makes
almost every noun better except war
anyway I've been thinking a lot about
sunsets this week because the ones here
in Michigan are so ostentatiously
beautiful like back home in Indiana the
light often gets gray and then grayer
until it's dark but here in Michigan at
least at this time of year
these sunsets are mundane they're
ordinary
which also makes them cliche of course I
mean the beauty of sunsets and the civil
Twilight's that follow is by now so
cliche that it's difficult to say
anything interesting about them like I
love coming famous sunset poem which
goes who are you little I five or six
years old peering from some high window
at the Gold of November sunset and
feeling that if day has to become night
this is a beautiful way it's a good poem
but it only works because coming
situates the observation in childhood
when one is presumably too innocent to
have yet realized how lame it is to
write about sunsets and yet a good
sunset is beautiful and better still
universally so like our ancestors didn't
eat like us or travel like us their
relationship to ideas as fundamental as
light and time were vastly different
from ours but every human who's lived
more than a few years on this planet has
seen a beautiful sunset and paused to
spend one of the last moments of day to
be grateful for and overwhelmed by the
light but even now I'm swimming in
sentimental waters how do you celebrate
a sunset without being cheesy may be
stated in cold facts so here's what
happens before a beam of sunlight gets
to your eyes it has millions of
interactions with molecules that cause
the so-called scattering of light
different wavelengths are sent off in
different directions when interacting
would say oxygen or nitrogen in the
atmosphere but at sunset the light
travels through the atmosphere longer
before it reaches our eyes so that much
of the blue and purple has been
scattered away before it reaches us I
think it's helpful to know how sunsets
work and I've never bought the romantic
notion that scientific understanding
somehow
Robb's the universe of its beauty but it
still doesn't communicate much about how
I felt
looking at this absolutely routine
totally unexplored anair e civil
twilight how it felt to look at
something that was as beautiful as it
was normal and to be comforted both by
the beauty and the normalcy so anyway I
tried to photograph it because you know
that's what people do but of course the
camera couldn't capture how I felt in
the space between yesterday and last
night and apparently neither can my
voice over all I can say is that
sometimes the world stops me cold and I
feel my smallness and you'd think that
would be sad but it isn't it only makes
me grateful Toni Morrison once wrote
that at some point in life the world's
beauty becomes enough you don't need to
photograph paint or even remember it it
is enough so I turned off my camera and
it was it was enough Hank I'll see you
on Friday